It's challenging to go to the UN and participate in the system where the
UN says, you know,
we have this formula and every country gets to have a certain amount of people
get jobs at the UN. So they look at the formula and they say, Oh, well,
how many people do we have from Nigeria? Oh,
we need more go hire people into the system from Nigeria.
It tends to not be whether or not someone is qualified or has the skillset.
It is,
are we being fair and equal on the disbursement of jobs?
And that's.
Where it breaks down because you're hiring people that really don't know what
they're doing. And they waste money in the UN becomes a jobs program.
Can you talk a little bit.
What about just generally what the state of the UN is and what it was like to be
there?
And you know that so many people think that it's like this sort of perfect
thing that the countries come together and figure out what's right.
For everybody. Like,
they love the idea of it more than I think functionally how it works or does not
work.
Well, first of all, the, uh.
I always try to correct people that, that the UN doesn't really exist.
The UN has member States, right? So when somebody says, Oh, the UN says, no,
I always say the UN doesn't say no members at the UN,
maybe Russia and China got together in the security council and said, no,
but the UN doesn't take a position. And so I,
I try to not just reflexively blame, Oh,
the UN stopped something. Cause it's really member countries.
That's the first thing. The second thing is,
is the UN does not work unless the U S is leading it.
Whether it's the world food program, UNICEF UN DP, you know,
the development programs, whatever it is, the U S has to be there.
Otherwise the UN does not work.
The UN system is based on every country is equal.
Not every person is equal, it's every country.
And that's where I think as Americans, we say,
that's just fundamentally not true. Every country is not equal.
So in the general assembly,
when we pretend that these small Island countries get the same vote as
China or the United States, or, you know, the bigger economies,
um, that's kind of laughable, to be honest, I get that.
We want to have a general assembly where people have the ability to talk,
but I don't love the idea of one country, one vote,
um, which I think is balanced by the security council and the,
and the idea that the substantive work goes to the security council.
So I get to the kind of separation. Um,
but it's challenging to go to the UN and participate in the system where
the UN says, you know,
we have this formula and every country gets to have a certain amount of people
get jobs at the UN. So they look at the formula and they say, Oh, well,
how many people do we have from Nigeria? Oh,
we need more go hire people into the system from Nigeria.
It tends to not be whether or not someone is qualified or has the skillset.
It is,
are we being fair and equal on the disbursement of jobs.
Out of this idea lately?
And that's where it breaks down because you're hiring people that really don't
know what they're doing. And they waste money in the UN becomes a jobs program.
Is the UN better at certain things and worse at others.
So like when it comes to food disbursement or helping development,
that kind of stuff, it seems like they're probably pretty decent at,
and then the security council or a lot of the rest of it seems like 90% of it is
just voting against Israel for yeah.
Yeah. For sure. Moving to rock. Um, yeah,
I think you hit it on the head is that, you know,
we pay 25% of the UN bill and that's for the
secretariat and the kind of UN administration.
Parking tickets. Right. Isn't it, isn't the whole thing. Just parking tickets.
Exactly. Not what they say. It's just ambassadors,
use the park wherever you want. Yeah.
Um, but at the same time, there are these what they call, um, uh,
extra bodies, independent bodies,
and those are funded through voluntary contributions.
So world food program in UNICEF,
they don't get monies from the,
the general fund of the 25% money that we give.
UNICEF only gets its budget by appealing to people say, to say,
we've got a crisis we need to go out. And who, who wants to write us a check?
The Europeans, the Germans, the Americans, we fund the most on those,
a world food program, UNICEF type, uh, independent bodies.
That's why they're the well run is because we demand management,
transparency and accountability, and these independent bodies,
we don't have that ability to do in the UN general assembly. So the,
you get this kind of
really blob type, uh,
management and,
and mission from the actual UN operations.
What is the obsession with Israel with the general assembly? I mean, every,
every time you look at that chart, it's like 90% of the condemnations.
And you know that there's only one country that can't serve on the security
council. That's Israel.
I'm outraged by it. I'm telling you, I think that,
that the U S government should just put its foot down and say,
we're going to clear the deck and Israel should be on the security council,
just to prove a point of, of, of getting them on the CA on the security council.
Um, it there's this fascination with condemning Israel.
It's why we got out of the human rights council is because, you know,
you've got nine resolutions on Israel and
nothing on, you know, Iran or, or, I mean, the word is out. If you,
if you don't want to be condemned by the UN and you're a human rights abuser,
then go run for the human rights council. So you can protect yourself, right.
Trump somehow just gets all this.
Like he really has fixed a lot of this or is in the process of fixing it or.
No, he's not of the political establishment.
And so he's willing to be a disruptor.
We all know about disruptive technology and people who go
in and say, gosh, everybody has group think, and you're missing the big,
you know, reform effort.
I think Americans really want Washington to be disrupted or the UN,
they, they look at it and they say, what a waste? You know,
why are we spending all that money?
But the system in Washington filled with lobbyists and,
and all the people that take care of each other,
they don't want an outsider coming in and somehow wrecking
their good fortune, you know? And, and we see that in Hollywood,
we see that same thing in Hollywood. And so I want to,
to applaud and do everything I can for president Trump, because first of all,
he's got really thick skin.
All of the people who just constantly come at him for w thank God we got a
president. Who's just really tough on that and doesn't care. And too,
he sees it for what it is. And he's not really that partisan. I mean,
I look at what I'm starting to call the Trump doctrine,
which I think is the Trump doctrine to foreign policy,
which is a dual approach to every single issue where you use every tool of
the U S government economic tool,
sanctions pressure to change the behavior of a country.
And you really utilize that pressure in a strong way. At the same time,
there's the separate path to say, let's talk,
let's sit down and have a diplomatic talk.
He's doing it with Kim Jong-un and the,
the neo-cons and the traditional Republicans did not like him saying,
I'm going to just go talk to Kim Jong-un they only want to do the squeezing.
They don't always want to say, well,
why not talk to see if we can test this talking as a tactic?
It's not, it's not the goal. Right? You see the, when you.
Then like the never Trump conservative.
So like the bill crystals are just those guys that have sort of been around
forever and who usually you've gotten everything wrong. Always,
are they different privately? Like, are they privately kind of like, yeah,
I like what he's doing. And he's.
So I think the creatures of Washington, I think they live in Washington DC.
And they, they, they want people to play by the rules,
the people who benefit from the rules and,
and they want everybody to come in and play by the rules are, uh,
on both sides of the aisle. This is not a partisan thing at all.
It's you got to come to our city and play by our rules because we got lobbyists
to take care of.
And we've got a system and everybody is participating in the system, right.
Marco Rubio actually talked about this just the other day.
And I thought it was really good. He was, he was saying, look,
when I came to Washington and I didn't go to their cocktail parties,
I eventually didn't get invited to their cocktail parties.
And then they started sniping at me because I wasn't going to their cocktail
parties. And I, and they recognized that I wasn't playing by the rules.
And he said, Trump has done it, tenfold he's come in and, and, you know,
completely, uh, double down on that. And, and I think it's right.
I think we're getting senators. You know, Ron Johnson,
I think is another great Senator who doesn't play that game. And he,
he comes from Wisconsin and plays a different tune,
which is I'm fighting for the people of Wisconsin. Marco Rubio, I think,
is doing that,
that we have senators that are beginning to do that and
challenge the system. Uh, and I think it's what the people want.
Uh, so what's it like when Trump, Donald Trump, New York businessman,
Donald Trump, the guy becomes president, then I assume your phone rings one day.
And he says, I'm looking to send somebody over to Germany. Is it a phone call?
Is it an email to someone else reach out to you first? How does that all work?
I had been, um, in and around the campaign quite a bit.
And so there's always a constant conversation. Um,
and there's also, I think a question of like, who's loyal, right? Who, who,
who was here before all of the jobs were available, um,
who was committed. And I think they saw that I was very committed in,
in the campaign. And so the conversation to me was,
you know, where do you see yourself in the administration,
or do you want to join the administration? And so from the beginning,
I just said, you know, some sort of a foreign policy role, you know, let's,
let's discuss. And then we had that conversation. And eventually I was like,
I think Germany is a good fit.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.